[Musique]
on est à la fois animés par un sentiment
de tristesse et de désolation
aujourd'hui des personnes ou des
professionnels qui veulent retrouver
leurs papiers leur diplôme seront
vraiment dans une situation assez
difficile étant donné qu'il y a des
archives qui seront perdus
définitivement qui ne pourront plus être
récupérés
[Musique]
les archives datent depuis la création
de la Faculté des Lettres en 1957
jusqu'en 2010 on avait aussi il y avait
aussi des archives de 2019 jusqu'à 2021
on n'a pas encore fait l'inventaire
l'état des lieux mais à peu près il y a
je dirais qu'il y a après 200 000
documents qui ont été brûlés
[Musique]
d'abord là nous faisons ce qu'on appelle
l'identification on essaie d'identifier
ce qui est là et de pouvoir connaître ce
qui peut être récupéré voilà parce que
on remarque il y a beaucoup d'archives
aujourd'hui qui ne peuvent pas être
récupéré ici on essaie de trier de se
voir qu'est-ce qui est récupérable de
traiter sa pièce par pièce et de
procéder à l'insertion
[Musique]